Joe Biden finally speaks about Tara
Reid's accusations the media
preemptively declare Georgia's opening a
failure and evidence mounts of the FBI's
manipulation of Michael Flynn I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN surfed the web with peace
of mind sign up now and expressvpn comm
slash Ben we're gonna get to all of the
news in a moment Joe Biden finally
speaks it's like Garbo speaks for people
who are movie history literate there was
an actress named Greta Garbo very famous
silent actress and when she finally
appeared in talkies that was the big
headline was Garbo speaks well Joe Biden
is unable to put together English
sentences and has been hiding out in his
basement for a while and he'd been
completely silent about the Tara Reid
allegations now he has finally spoken
and it didn't go awesome we'll get to
that in just a second first let's talk
about the fact that you're lounging
around right now but you also need to
look decent for your zoom meeting that
is gonna be taking place later today the
boss doesn't want to see you once again
in those ratty old sweatshirts he
doesn't want to see you at the ratty old
sweatshirts and the unkempt hair look
good and be comfortable with Tommy John
Tommy John has something for everyone no
matter what you are working from home
situation is from super soft and
breathable underwear for answering
emails in bed to loungewear for when you
are running to get takeout Tommy John is
here to keep you comfortable right now
Tommy John is offering all customers 25%
off site-wide treat yourself upgrade to
a few pairs of Tommy John underwear in
the softest most most most breathable
fabrics you have ever worn these things
are great not just for men I'm learning
some time in cons right now but also for
women the Tommy John undergarments women
are fantastic my wife loves them she in
fact asked me to order some extras of
them all of Tommy John's lamb wears and
leggings loungewear and leggings are
built for next level comfort whether
you're in the hunt for lounge pants or
sleep shorts or lazing around joggers
Tommy John has got you covered these
make a great Mother's Day gift as well
remember get your order in before May
7th and you can ensure delivery by
mother's day Tommy John is so confident
in their underwear that if you don't
love your first pair you can get a full
refund with their best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guaranteed Tommy John
no adjustment needed once you go Tommy
John you won't go back where you Tommy
John comm / Ben right now for 25% off
your order that is Tommy John comm / Ben
for 25% off right now Tommy John comm /
bed and see the site for details Tommy
John comm / Ben ok so joe biden's hens
have a rough 24 hours a very rough 24
hours so here's what happened at the
over the past 48 hours the dam has
started to break on the Tara Reid
allegation so Tara Reid came out almost
over a month ago I believe and made the
allegation that back in 1993 when she
was a Senate staffer for Joe Biden he
called her into a little-used corridor
in the Senate and there he proceeded to
sexually molest her essentially like
pick up her skirt and then put his
fingers inside her like actual
penetration
penetrative sexual assault I mean it's a
sexual assault by definition any
penetration forcible penetration is
sexual assault
so she alleged this and then everybody
ignored it and then she came forward
with a bunch of people who she had told
contemporaneously now that is not this
positive for people in the media who
don't understand the word dispositive
this positive means that does not mean
that the case is disposed of because of
these allegations meaning just because
you told somebody at the time something
happened doesn't mean it went down that
way doesn't mean that you remembered
correctly but it does mean that you've
been telling the story for 30 years they
didn't make it up in the last five
minutes so Tara Reid originally had a
couple people she had told she told her
mom just like she told her brother her
mom called in to Larry King Live and
actually made sort of oblique reference
to it back in 1993 and then it turned
out there are two additional people who
said on the record that she had told
them about this allegation so all of
this starts to mount because after all
the Democratic Party has been pushing
they believe all women hashtag me to
movement for years mainly to get Trump
remember nobody care about Harvey
Weinstein in Hollywood for years and
then Trump was elected it was like okay
we're gonna have to get rid of all these
bad bad terrible men sure we had Bill
Clinton in sure we had JFK and sure we
had Ted Kennedy and sure we had Chris
Dodd and sure we had you know a lot of
people were sort of famously going
around town in molesting women but or
allegedly molesting women but at the
same time you know they were important
people Trump we got to get out of office
now it's time to change the standard
we'll hold ourself to a better standard
and they did overtly change the standard
senator Kirsten Gillibrand who had been
hobnobbing with the Clintons turned on a
dime and said if I had been around when
Bill Clinton was doing this maybe we
should have gotten rid of Bill Clinton
in 1998 after all over the Monica
Lewinsky and Paula Jones stuff maybe we
should have gone ahead and done that
okay well now Joe Biden is the nominee
and this allegation comes forward and
Joe Biden's original strategy is will
have Wilpon understatement denying it
and then that that's all we're gonna go
bad we're just gonna sit here silently
and the media basically go along with
this Tara Reid the person who made the
allegation is not asked on a single
national news show there's an entire
article in The New York Times yes
about this by Ben Smith who's actually
doing a pretty good job over at the New
York Times used to be the
editor-in-chief of her BuzzFeed now he's
reporting over at the New York Times
he's the media columnist and he says and
he says the mainstream American media in
1999 for reasons that are hard to
explain are excused today
got cold feet on a credible allegation
of rape against the president he's
referring to Juanita Broderick after NBC
News sat for weeks on an exclusive
interview
Broderick went on to the only people who
would listen to her mr. Clinton's
partisan enemies at The Wall Street
Journal editorial page that move helped
turn her straightforward allegation into
a weaponized political story and while
Americans watching at home to make up
their own minds about Juanita
Broderick's credibility they were left
with new reasons to shake their head at
the media the same thing is about to
happen again
a former Senate aide for Joe Biden Tara
Reed has accused the presumptive
Democratic presidential nominee of
sexually assaulting her in 1993
reporters have found other accounts that
indicate she's been telling her version
of events for a long time there are as
with Juanita Broderick reasons to doubt
her story there aren't good reasons not
to hear her out and yet Reed told me
Wednesday the only offers she's had to
appear on television have come from Fox
News and call including a call from
primetime host Sean Hannity she has so
far turned them down she said I've been
trying to just kind of wait to get
someone in the middle I don't want to be
pigeonholed as a progressive I don't
want to be pigeonholed as a trump
supporter CNN MSNBC MSNBC whose DNA even
a pandemic his politics have covered her
on their websites in on air but have not
put her on camera Reid said they're not
offering to put me on TV they're just
doing stories no anchors nothing like
that she'd most like to tell her story
to a network television anchor she
admires CBS's Gayle King is one she said
but they haven't called so she is
planning to accept Fox News's offer for
an interview to air this weekend but
with someone a little more up the middle
apparently she's going to talk with
Chris Wallace that is something that is
that that she's been considering Ben
Smith says some of the reasons this
story seems muffled right now are fairly
straightforward the global coronavirus
pandemic there's also the way miss Reed
first tried getting attention mostly on
Twitter stumbling forward with no PR
person and no attorney since I emailed
Ronan Farrow like four times some points
of stalking and I didn't hear back now
of course he's one of the investigators
were investigative reporters on this
Reid said that she had meant that Farrow
had not initially responded to her but
they were now actively communicating
then she found partisans willing to hear
her out remember this allegation first
aired on a Bernie Sanders Pro Bernie
Sanders podcast by a woman named Katie
helper than the intercept which is also
a leftist website reported that a friend
and brother of Miss reads recalled her
describing at the instant
the traditional media waited and
carefully then Business Insider had
reported the reporter rich McHugh at
first taken the story to Vanity Fair and
Vanity Fair wouldn't publish it
can you imagine Vanity Fair not
publishing Christine blazing forward
story of course not
the broadcast television network CNN and
MSNBC have covered the story on their
websites but there's been no clear
explanation for why Reid was not booked
on mainstream TV CNN and MSNBC declined
to explain why they have not booked a
woman who is whether you believe her or
not one of the few news makers right now
who could cut through that pandemic the
posture is all the more strange mean
this is a great piece by Ben Smith he's
actually being honest here the posture
is all the more strange because at this
point it's essentially symbolic in 1999
you could argue that NBC's decision to
hold back Lisa Myers his interview with
Broderick had real political
consequences taped in January as the
Senate took up impeachment charges
against Clinton it didn't air until
after the Senate voted not to convict
the president in February back then the
only way Americans were gonna hear her
voice was on television but these days
if you want a judge read story you can
listen to the original podcast interview
you can find her talking about it in
different places so it's pretty amazing
that TV has refused to have Tara Reed on
and it does demonstrate the bias of the
media remember Christine Blasi Ford was
put on the cover of Time magazine with
her face comprised of various quotes
from her about all the horrible things
that happened to her in a hero's pose
holding up her hand and taking the oath
to tell nothing about the truth the
whole truth but matera read they won't
even have on national TV they'll have on
clowns like Sean Penn to talk about the
global pandemic but they won't have on
Tara Reid who's making an actual
allegation of direct sexual assault
against a presidential candidate there
Willingham on everybody who's making
those sorts of allegations against Trump
back in 2016 but when it comes to Joe
Biden complete silence from national TV
so Joe Biden rightly thought he could
hide out from this for quite a while and
now it turns out by the way that Joe
Biden is doing more to hide out from the
story we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about the fact
that if your car is having trouble right
now the Internet has a solution for that
trouble you should take care of that
right now why I like it there's not a
worse time ever to go to an auto parts
store first of all you shouldn't have to
go to an auto parts store anyway
rockauto.com has you covered
they've got cheaper parts they have
better parts because the parts are gonna
be specifically matched to your car go
check out rockauto.com they always offer
the lowest possible prices rather than
changing price
based on what the market will bear like
Airlines do my spent up to twice as much
for the same parts chain stores have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers Rock
Auto comes prices are the same for
everybody they don't reliably low
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear
like Airlines to rockauto.com is for
everybody and does not require
membership or account login best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
check them out at Rock Auto calm
literally this is the worst time in
history to go to an autoparts store
except for 100 automobiles didn't exist
go to Rock Auto calm right now and see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro and their how did
you hear about us box so they know that
we sent you that's Rock Auto calm right
repear oh and there how did you hear
about us spots we really appreciate that
ok so joe biden is also engaging in a
bit of a cover-up here what i mean by
that is that joe biden has been asked to
open his personal papers to inspection
so he donated his senate papers his
personal senate papers to the university
of delaware and now he's running for
president well that would be a pretty
good time to you know actually reveal
those personal papers from the archive
if you didn't want to donate them joe
you shouldn't have donated them but the
idea that we are going to keep them in
the dark and and make them irrelevant
for years on end in the middle of this
is pretty ridiculous
it's amazing the media will go totally
after trump about not releasing his tax
records for the record i said many times
from she releases tax records
I think full transparency from
presidential candidates is a very good
thing the American public deserves to
know more by the way I felt the same
thing about things like Barack Obama's
College records I thought that was
interesting I thought it would be good
to know what kind of classes he took
back when he was in college and what
kind of papers he was writing and all of
that I mean some of them in public since
we were 17 so I sort of like the idea
that if you are in the Senate on the
taxpayer dime and you have notes that
you have donated to a public university
I believe University of Delaware's a
public university that you should now
have to release those as a condition of
running like this this seems like a
thing that you should do but apparently
Joe Biden will not release those records
Tara Reid says I'm calling for the
release of the documents being held by
the University of Delaware that
contained Biden's staff personnel
records because I believe it will have
my complaint form as well as my
separation letter in other documents
maybe if other staffers that have tried
to file complaints would come to light
why are they under seal why won't they
be released to the public so Biden's
campaign has denied the claim from read
Biden says that that there won't be any
references in the records 20 of this but
you could just release the records you
could you know Biden today suggested
that the records won't exist there that
they'll only exist at the National
Archives there's only one problem people
called up the National Archives and said
you have personnel records from Senate
offices they said no that's not we do
here the National Archives so no you're
actually going to have to release those
records and Biden is holding those
records pretty close to the chest so all
of this starts to mount this week so
it's amazing media don't ask Biden about
it for weeks on it right the last Stacy
Abrams about at the last Kirsten
Gillibrand about his lost Camilla Harris
about it the last gaming Club which are
about it the last Trump about it they
asked Trump about it yesterday
and frankly Trump was kind of
circumspect about it considering that
Trump is usually the guy who Agee Hanuma
brick and he will clock you directly in
the forehead with it instead Trump was
actually kind of circumspect because in
Trump's opinion he's been falsely
maligned about this sort of stuff many
times and so he's not gonna jump to
guilt well that's actually Trump being
consistent shockingly enough right Trump
saying listen I know all about false
accusation so I'm not gonna suggest that
Joe Biden is guilty merely because an
accusation was been that's actually
trumping far more consistent than Joe
Biden has ever been on this stuff here
is Trump I don't know anything about it
I don't know exactly I think he should
respond you know but so it could be
false accusations like know all about
false accusations I've been falsely
charged numerous times and there is such
a thing if you look at if you look at
Brett Kavanaugh there's an outstanding
man but I don't know I can't speak for
Biden I can only say that I think he
should respond I think he should answer
them okay and that is it that is it that
is a fairly circumspect answer again
from the President of the United States
so in the middle of all of the skin the
momentum is gaining and then intro Biden
has himself a couple of awful days awful
political days here's an example
yesterday Joe Biden was on national TV
and true Biden literally suggested on
national TV quote I view myself as a
transition candidate my job is to bring
the mayor piece of the world into this
administration so he's openly
acknowledging that he's not actually the
candidate for president that he is just
a dead person right you can't openly
acknowledge that and run for president I
mean if he had said that on the stage
you imagine if you'd said that on the
stage
imagine if he had said on the stage -
listen I got nothing new to offer you
know people know my name I'm kind of a
corpse and you know if you elect me then
mayor Pete will be President maybe
people been like I'm right here dude
like if I want to be people want me they
can vote for me why exactly would you
vote for a guy who in a general election
who is actually Kamala Harris or who is
actually mayor Pete or who is actually
Amy Klobuchar I mean it's an amazing
statement he's basically betting that
people hate Trump so much that he's
elected president that may not be a bad
bet but it's a horrible campaign tactic
suggesting that you are running not
because you have a vision for the
country or because you add anything to
the political debate but because you are
an empty vessel who is likely to
collapse and die two years into your
term this is the first time in my
lifetime that the VP selection is
actually gonna matter a lot if Joe Biden
selects Kamala Harris Donald Trump will
run against common law Harris he will
not even run against Joe Biden he will
say Joe Biden has said he's a transition
candidate Joe Biden is senile and not
healthy by the way Joe Biden does look
see now and not healthy and that is
perfectly that is perfectly acceptable
to say people say oh that's HS no it's
not a Juris there's plenty of 80 year
old people who don't look like Joe Biden
I should take violin lessons when I name
an Abrams stern amazing violin teacher
he was 80 vibrant totally with it not
Joe Biden hey we all know this maybe
it's in politic to say this too bad in a
presidential race there's no such thing
as in politic by the way everybody on
the Left have been speculating that
Trump is a few is a few apples short of
a barrel for a long time so suggesting
the Joe Biden does not he's not even Joe
Biden of eight years ago right Joe Joe
Biden cannot string sentences together
I'll show you proof that Joe Biden can
string sentences together actually hey
Jay here's a video yesterday of Joe
Biden suggesting that what he wants to
do about coronavirus is fly flags at
half-staff in the White House this is
his big suggestion to Carol coronavirus
is that he's gonna lower the flag to
half-staff at the White House that Wow
problem solved Joe and this was a video
the campaign released because they
thought it made Joe Biden look good Joe
Biden books like he cannot string a
sentence together he repeats himself no
less than twice in the foot in the
course of about a 45 second video he
stumbles over himself and his big
suggestion for curing coronavirus is
he's going to lower the flag at the
White House which is just wow problem
solved here Joe here is the vice
presidential here's the the presidential
candidate for the Democrats
Jake will go 29
by the end of this month we have lost
more people in the coronavirus dead and
we lost the entire Vietnam War Americans
lost the entire Vietnam War you know I
think the president should lower the
flag on the White House to half-mast to
recognize that loss and all they need
behind all those families behind vidiian
were first responders who gave their
life trying to save other lives folks I
think if he does not do that they
thought that this was this is a good
video for Joe Biden
so he's campaigning his corpse the
problem is a corpse who allegedly
sexually molested someone in 1993 does
not quite as good a candid as a corpse
you didn't do that right he doesn't have
the fictions out there and so what
you've seen is some of the Democrats
starting come out of the woodwork and in
a bit of a gap opening up in the
Democratic Party all this is lead up to
his disastrous appearance on Morning Joe
this morning it was really really bad
for him we're gonna get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that now more than ever with this
level of economic uncertainty you need
to be on top of your business data it is
imperative that you're on top of your
business data there's enough uncertainty
to go around right now the only way to
keep your business in the black or even
running at this point is to be granular
about your approach to your own
information this is why NetSuite exists
NetSuite will reduce your uncertainty by
giving you visibility and control with
so many critical decisions to make you
need the right numbers you need them
right now
NetSuite by Oracle is the world's number
one cloud business system with NetSuite
will give you financials cash flow
payroll inventory and more all in one
place to have clear visibility and total
control of your business
NetSuite customers have the flexibility
to work from anywhere with immediate
clarity on critical information directly
at their fingertips no more guessing no
more waiting make smarter decisions with
confidence because you've got crystal
clear visibility into your numbers join
over 20,000 companies who trust in that
suite to stay in control it's
irresponsible business not to be on top
of your data right now be responsible
get NetSuite receive your free guide
managing business uncertainty and
schedule your free product tour right
now at NetSuite comm slash Shapiro that
is ne tes yeux ite dot-com / Shapiro get
that free guide schedule that free
product tour NetSuite comm / up here o
once more NetSuite dot-com / appear ok
so you start to see the gap open up in
the Democratic Party and this is when
Biden has 2 on TV so you have the
the true believers like Nancy Pelosi
first I need to show you this tape that
was I'm not sure we compiled it but it's
it's totally correct
Nancy Pelosi on Tara Reid vs. Christine
Blasi Ford so here's what she had to say
about Christine Blasi floor back when
justice Cavanaugh was being questioned
remember the the phrase credible
incredibly accused is being thrown
around a lot credibly accused have you
incredibly accused about Tara Reid there
is more evidence that Tara Reid actually
he's been telling the story for the same
story for 30 years than there ever was
the Christine Blasi Ford was telling the
truth
Tara Reid is a much more credible
witness than christine Blasi Ford
flat-out Christine Blasi Ford made an
allegation and not a single thing that
she said was verifiable none of it Tara
Reid at least can point to a bunch of
people she said I told them at the time
right so here is Nancy Pelosi suggesting
that that Christine Blasi Ford should be
believed that justice Kavanagh was
probably a rapist and then we'll hear
her on terror and then we'll hear her on
Tara Reid and suffice it to say she is
at not consistence there's been
statements from his campaign or not his
campaign but his former employees who
ran his offices and the rest that there
was never any record of this instead of
asking questions the Republican
leadership fears the truth there was
never any record and that nobody ever
came forward or nobody really they're so
afraid of the truth and they're so
afraid a woman died dr. Christine Blasi
fought for the truth that she was still
Wow so that's what she had to say about
Christine Blasi for way back when Tara
Reid very different story yesterday
Pelosi was asked about this and she
started getting angry at reporters by
the way this we've been told that every
time a politician gets angry at a
reporter ever since Donald Trump that
this is an attack on the Free Press
listen to this vicious attack on the
Free Press putting all of our freedoms
at stake
how dare dancey Pelosi here is Nancy
Pelosi looking worse and worse these
days honestly I mean there's a stressful
time for her being basically ripped up
and down by the media and being forced
to to suggest she doesn't need a lecture
I respect your question and I don't need
a lecture or speech here's the thing I
have a complete respect for homie to
movement I have four daughters and once
and there's a lot of excitement around
the idea that women will be heard and be
will listen to there is also due process
and the fact that Joe Biden is Joe Biden
yeah Joe Biden is Joe Biden's this is
trending yesterday Joe Biden is Joe Vitt
first of all Joe Biden is Joe Biden I
just don't know if Joe Biden knows that
anymore with us but Joe Biden is Joe
Biden isn't that exactly the case that
was being made for Brett Kavanaugh
people were saying well here's a bunch
of women that Brett Kavanaugh knew who
he never never could imagine that he
would do anything like this but I'm
saying well that's not good evidence
that you can't say that he isn't the
woman making me those aren't the women
making the accusation Joe Biden is Joe
Biden is not a defense
so some many Democrats begin to begin to
buck against this Hakeem Jeffries from
New York he says well you know what
maybe we should investigate those maybe
we should actually take a look at this
and the damn starts to break there's got
to be taken seriously because it's a
serious allegation raised by a serious
individual and needs to be investigated
seriously but in terms of what the
appropriate mechanism is you know that
remains to be seen
I've got a dive deeper into the evidence
that has emerged and I've also got to
dive deeper into Joe Biden's response
and we probably should hear from him at
some point directly as it relates to the
allegation all right so the dam starts
to break and people start asking why
isn't Joe Biden going on TV why won't
you Biden answer questions so morning
joe books Joe Biden on this and this
morning Joe Biden appears on Morning Joe
presumably because he thinks he's gonna
get a fairly warm treatment after all
Mika and Joe are not exactly warm to
president Trump these days this is not
2016 anymore and 2016 they were fairly
friendly with Trump all the way through
the primaries then of course from turned
into orange man bad but Joe Biden
probably expected fairly easy treatment
instead Mika Brzezinski clocked him with
just a cartoon mallet she went directly
at him and she has precisely the kinds
of questions that Democrats were asking
about Brett Kavanaugh and by the way
people who are angry at Mika you should
have been angry when Democrats were
asking this stuff about Brett Kavanaugh
or about Donald Trump at least Mika
Brzezinski is holding to a consistent
standard now I think the standard is
stupid by the way I don't think the
standard should be if you are asked
about an allegation you say the
allegation is false you don't have to
justify why you say the allegation is
false and if someone accuses you of rape
and you say that never happened you then
do not have to say but the woman's story
you know we should we should totally
take our story seriously you're allowed
to say no that could the story's
complete crap
sorry I don't know why she would do that
the stories it's garbage and I'm angry
that I've been accused of something I
didn't do that's called a normal human
reaction and the fact we live in a
stupid time or if you are accused of a
crime that you did not commit you are
supposed to be in some way tolerant of
the person who is making the accusation
is insane I mean the standard is hella
stupid that was a standard set by
Democrats
okay so Mika Brzezinski actually holds
the same standard for Brett Kavanaugh
and Joe Biden can't hold up to the
standard you know why not cuz Joe Biden
is guilty but because no one can hold up
to the standard cuz the standards
idiotic the standard is moronic from the
very start the standard that if I ben
shapiro were accused of sexual assault I
said are you insane are you an insane
person I'm an Orthodox Jew I've only had
sex with one person in my entire life
and I'm married to her and it was after
I was married to her are you out of your
damn minds and whoever makes that
accusation is is scurrilous it's
disgusting and if I were to say that it
would you're not respecting the woman
why the hell should I respect someone
who's being a false accusation about me
right it's an idiotic standard but that
is the standard Democrats are using you
have to you have to believe all women
even if you're the one who knows it's
not true so no one can hold up to that
standard and predictably enough Joe
Biden who held that standard doesn't
hold up to the standard which is why
again it was the a terrible appearance
by Joe Biden for a couple of reasons
we'll get to those in just one second
the biggest reason because anybody who's
asked these questions cannot answer them
basically Mika Brzezinski asked Joe
Biden senator when did you stop beating
your wife that's the famous sort of
formulation of questions that cannot be
answered when did you stop beating your
wife right because the implication is of
course that you started beating your
wife the question itself is the
condemnation we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that we all have regrets in life
how do we get things so wrong like
joining Twitter for example life life
regrets waste of time terrible people
but you know that's life you make
mistakes but here's one thing you really
can't afford to make a mistake about
that is life insurance why because by
the time you correct a mistake you're
dead we really needed to make sure that
you had that life insurance has a worse
human being this is why you need policy
genius.com policy genius makes finding
the right life insurance a breeze in
minutes you can compare you quotes from
the top insurers and find your best
price you could say fifteen hundred
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy it can also help you find
the right home and auto insurance or
disability insurance so even if you look
back on the days before Twitter and you
think ah wasn't that a better time the
fact is you don't have to regret
anything if you go get your life
insurance right now from policy genius
com protecting your family against the
evil vicissitudes of life go check out
policy genius calm life insurance
disabilities insurance home and auto
insurance shop competitively save
yourself money and don't waste your time
go to policy genius calm once more
that's policy genius.com go check them
out right now ok so finally Joe Biden
appears on Morning Joe and it does not
go well so morning so Micah asks him a
couple of different lines one is so Joe
you you used to say believe all women
you said that you thought that Christine
Blasi Ford was credibly accusing Brett
Kavanaugh
what happened why shouldn't we hold you
to the same standard and here was Joe
Biden's answer from the very beginning
I've said believing women means taking
the woman's claims seriously where she
steps forward and and then vet it look
into it this is that that's true in this
case as well women have a right to be
heard and the pressured rigorously
investigate claims they make I'll always
uphold that principle but in the end in
every case the truth is what matters and
in this case the truth is the claims are
false she says that my standard was that
we should rigorously investigate
anything and the claims are false that
was not his standard this was not his
standard he says I'm saying
unequivocally it never happened it
didn't it never happened but again the
reality is that Joe Biden did not hold
that standard until five seconds ago Joe
Biden has completely shifted his
standard his standard was no his
standard was I'm not going to I'm you
know I think that if a woman makes an
accusation then we will believe her but
now it's unless it's me in which case
you should totally fully investigate
this here's what Biden's
in 2018 for a woman to come forward in
the glare and light to focus nationally
you've got to start off with the
presumption that at least the essence of
what she's talking about is real whether
or not she forgets facts whether or not
it's been made worse or better over time
so Brzezinski asked is the essence of
what she is saying real why do you think
she's doing this and Biden says I'm not
gonna question her motive I'm not gonna
get into that at all I don't know why
she's saying this I don't know why after
27 years all of a sudden this gets
raised I don't understand that but I'm
not gonna go in and question her motive
I'm not gonna attack her she has the
right to say whatever she wants to say
but I have a right say look at the facts
check it out find out if what she says
is true
Brzezinski then followed up she says as
it pertains to Christine Blasi Ford
high-level Democrat said she should be
believed you said if someone like dr.
Ford were to come out the essence of
what she was saying has to be believed
why why is it real for dr. Ford but not
for Tara Reid and Biden saying Biden
says I'm not suggesting she has no right
to come forward any woman they should be
heard and then it should be investigated
and if there's anything that is
consistent with what's being said and
she makes the case or the case is made
it should be believed but only the truth
matters again he is now shifting back to
due process which should have been the
original standard but the problem is
that was never his standard no one
cannot that the point of this no one can
uphold the standards the Democrats set
for Brett Kavanaugh and this is the
point many of us were making at the time
that you have set a bar that is
impossible to surpass it is impossible
it is literally the guilt is the
accusation because believe all women all
women have to be taken seriously no
matter how outlandish their claims no
matter if they're claiming that Brett
Kavanaugh was lining up women and
buffing them in high school and that
booth actually meant not getting drunk
but raping people right the whole thing
was ridiculous and Joe Biden held by
that and then she asked another
follow-up Mika Brzezinski along the same
line she said Stacey Abrams said during
the Cavanagh hearings I believe women I
believe survivors of assault should be
supported and voice is heard Kirsten
Gillibrand Sweta do we believe women do
we give women an opportunity to tell
their story we must be a country that
says yes every time they now both
support you are women to be believed
unless it pertains to you and Biden says
women are to be believed given the
benefit of the doubt if they come
forward and say something that they said
happens then they should start off with
the presumption that they are telling
the truth
then you have to look at the
circumstances and the facts and the
facts in this case do not exist they
never happened okay so now he is
shifting his standard which makes him
look pretty bad because again the
standard was never capable of being
upheld and may be done
Kratts are willing to allow this sort of
shifting standard and maybe it's better
for the world if we go back to a
rational standard I think it is but
let's just acknowledge what happened
here that the Democrats shifted their
standard from Nina Burrell a Time
magazine piece in which she claimed that
she would perform a Lewinsky on Bill
Clinton in order to maintain the
propriety of abortion and they moved
from we don't care about sexual assault
if it's a Democrat - every woman must be
believed when it was Donald Trump who's
in the crosshairs and then they move
from that - you know what be great due
process when it's Joe Biden back in the
cross hair so just understand there are
no standards for Democrats none I've
held the same standard all the way
through allegations have to be
substantiated by actual evidence that
should be the standard for all of these
things should it not hey now Joe Biden
then Joe Biden was asked on make a
Brzezinski about the document release
over at University of Delaware and he
seemed stunned that he's even being
asked the question now he's released a
statement trying to clarify here he was
being stunned I mean first of all Joe
Biden has a perennial look of being
stunned these days because he again he
is not with us but here's here's Mika
Brzezinski and Joe Biden there are no
personnel documents but you can't do
that you wouldn't for example if you
worked with mayor I worked for you and
you had my my income tax returns you had
my whatever their their private
documents they're not for them they
don't they don't get put out in the
public they're not part of the public
record
that in fact is that any senator or vice
president and their president has in
their documents so question um why did
you give them to the University of
Delaware I basically are okay with
people perusing your notes just not
right now
so what you're then you shouldn't turn
them over buddy okay he puts out a full
statement today and the gall of the man
here here's here's Joe Biden's full
statement that he put out on Friday
morning quote April is Sexual Assault
Awareness Month every year at this time
we talk about awareness prevention and
the importance of women feeling they can
step forward say something and be heard
that belief that women should be heard
was the underpinning of the law I wrote
over 25 years ago to this day I am most
proud of the Violence Against Women Act
so each April we were reminded not only
of how far we have come in dealing with
sexual assaults in this country but how
far we still have to go so again he's
being I'm gonna use the phrase
incredibly accused because I guess now
that's the phrase that we use credibly
accused of sexual assault
and he opens his statement with here all
the great things have done for me I was
reliably informed that it does not
matter whether you've treated women well
your entire career that has no relevance
to sexual assault allegation
I was reliably informed of that when it
came to both Donald Trump and Brett
Kavanaugh actually Biden continues when
I wrote the bill if you wanted to talk
about the issue it was considered a
private matter a personal matter a
family matter I didn't see it that way
to me freedom from fear harm and
violence for woman was a legal right a
civil right and a human right and I knew
we had to change not only the law but
the culture so we held hours of hearings
and heard from the most incredibly brave
women we opened the eyes of the Senate
in the nation we passed the law in the
years that followed I can I fought to
continually strengthen the law so when
we took office and President Obama asked
me what I wanted I told him I wanted
oversight of the critical appointments
in the office on violence against women
at the DOJ and I wanted a senior White
House adviser appointed directly to me
on the issue both of those things happen
as Vice President we started the it's on
us campaign on college campuses to send
the message loud and clear that dating
violence is violence and against the law
we had to get men about so there's this
long preamble about all of these
wonderful things that he has done for
for women and then he says it's on us
and it's on me as someone who wants to
lead this country I recognize my
responsibility to be a voice in advocate
and a leader for the change in culture
that has begun but is nowhere near
finished so I want to address
allegations by a former staffer that I
engaged in misconduct 227 years ago well
no the allegation is that you forcibly
sexually assaulted her not that you
engaged in misconduct
he says they aren't true this never
happened while the details of these
allegations of sexual harassment and
sexual assaults are complicated two
things are not complicated one is that
women's deserve to be treated with
dignity and respect and when they step
forward they should be heard not
silenced the second is that their
stories should be subject to appropriate
inquiry and scrutiny again there's that
shifting standard appropriate inquiry
and scrutiny apparently did not involve
you know actual scrutiny and inquiry for
Christine Blasi Ford or any of the women
Donald Trump was involved with or any of
the rest of us responsible news
organizations should examine and
evaluate the full and growing record of
inconsistencies in her story which has
changed repeatedly in both small and big
ways but this much bears emphasizing she
has said she raised some of these issues
with her supervisor and senior staffers
from my office at the time they both men
and a woman have said unequivocally she
never came to them and complained or
raised issues news organizations that
have talked with literally dozens of
former staffers and not found one not
one who corroborated her allegations in
any way indeed many of them spoke to the
culture of an office
would not have tolerated harassment in
any way as indeed I would not have there
is a clear critical part of the story
that can be verified the former staffer
has said she filed a complaint back in
1993 but she does not have a record of
this alleged complaint the papers for my
Senate years that I donated to the
University of Delaware do not contain
personnel files it is the practice of
senators to establish a library of
personal papers that document their
public record speeches policy proposals
positions taken in the writing of bills
there's only one place a complaint of
this kind could be the National Archives
there is only one problem with this this
is not true this is not true okay it is
it is Anna Nicole I'm binder who is a
who is a reporter for I'm trying to see
which outlet
Business Insider she says this is not
right she says the National Archives
does not hold records from the personnel
office the Office of Fair Employment
Practices instead a Senate historical
office staffer said the Fair Employment
Practices records are governed by Senate
resolution mandating that records
containing personal privacy information
closed by statute and records of
executive nomination are closed for 50
years that staffer said that the rules
for filing a complaint to the Office of
Fair Employment Practices were
complicated and it was possible a staff
are attempting to do so without proper
guidance may not have taken the
necessary steps to get an investigation
started according to the congressional
testimony from 1995 479 people contacted
the office between 1992 and 1995 seeking
assistance of those only 102 entered the
offices five-step dispute resolution
process which included a formal
complaint and hearing if reads complaint
was filed to the Office of Fair
Employment Practices the record will
remain closed until 2040 3 2014 3 also
it is possible the reason that she wants
the University of Delaware records
exposed is because there are actual
records because she met formally and
informally with several Biden aides
according to her including his former
chief of staff Ted Kaufman about her
concerns which included allegations she
was told she dressed you provocatively
and asked to drinks to serve drinks at a
fundraiser because Biden liked her legs
she believes notes from those
discussions would be in any personnel
files the archive might contain so it's
not just about a formal complaint it's
also about did Joe Biden ever mention
her in any of his notes he refuses to
release those notes and now he's putting
out a statement lying about how he can't
release those notes so he says as a
presidential candidate I'm accountable
to the American people we've moved
long enough with the president who
doesn't think he's accountable to anyone
and takes responsibility for nothing and
then he goes on and talks about how we
need to stop gender-based violence etc
etc etc bottom line is utterly
insufficient from Joe Biden not by his
own standard not by his own standard and
by the standards the people held for
Trump by the way so does that really
damage Joe Biden in a race against Trump
he can always point to Trump on a
comparative level he can say listen he
has a far worse history than I do have
bad allegations and that's true it is a
hundred percent true it is also true
that Joe Biden was perceived widely by
the media as pure as the driven snow
not anymore it's gonna be difficult for
him to have these allegations dogging
him the rest of the race okay in just a
moment we're gonna get to all of your
corona virus updates we ought by the way
quick further note on Joe Biden Joe
Biden also has now enlisted chris dodd
to aid in his search for a female vice
president the Connecticut Democrat
allegedly assaulted a waitress during
his tenure there there's a famous story
with Chris Dodd and Ted Kennedy were
sandwich and waitresses that's literally
what that was in a report from Michael
Kelly writing for GQ quote it is after
midnight and Kennedy and Dodd are just
finishing up a long dinner in a private
room on the first floor of the
restaurant annex they are drunk their
dates two very young blondes leave the
table to go to the bathroom the dates
are drunk too they'd always get their
girls very very drunks as a former
Brasserie waitress Betty Lowe who served
the foursome also leaves the room
apparently a woman named Karla Cavalli
oh it says is told that the Senators
want to see her as gavel enters the room
the six-foot to 225 pound plus Kennedy
grabs the five-foot three one hundred
three pound waitress and throws her on
the table
Kennedy then picks her up from the table
and throws her on Dodd who is sprawled
in a chair and then Kennedy jumps on top
and begins rubbing his genital area
against her supporting his weight on the
arms of the chair Chris Dodd is there
the whole time and involved in this in
this sandwich Inge Dodd she adds
says it's not my fault okay so that
that's the guy that Joe Biden just chose
to help him search for a female vice
president so a good look there from from
the Biden campaign okay we're gonna move
on to other it matters that I think
concern people more namely are we all
going to die or not we'll get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that your favorite devices are
a major source of blue light and this
means they're keeping you up at night
right if you if you are playing with
your phone right before bed it is likely
to keep you up your on your screen so
much now because we are all stuck at
home
is very important protect your eyes from
that blue light and give you headaches
it can keep you awake at night which
leads to greater stress levels what you
need is a good looking pair of Felix
gray glasses there are lots of
situations where you could get involved
in eye strain gives you headaches common
symptoms from spending too much time in
front of screens and things like blurry
vision and tired eyes stop with the blue
light instead get the Felix square glass
I have a pair I wear them a lot they are
great many blue blue light glasses don't
actually filter enough blue light
especially in the range that matters
screens produce the most blue light at a
certain point in the spectrum namely 455
nanometers most clear blue light lenses
only filter about two to three percent
in that range but Felix gray uses a
proprietary filtering technology to
filter 15 times more blue light in the
same exact range order online the
glasses will ship directly to you with a
hard case and lens cloth included by the
way these things are much more durable
you'll actually see people marketing
blue light glasses online where the film
is sort of painted on them and then they
start cracking and they start bubbling
and they fall apart really easily not
Felix squared this stuff is gonna last
you a lifetime this week only Felix gray
is giving you 15% off all glasses at
Felix spread glasses comm slash Ben head
unordered Felix great glasses comm slash
Ben and tur Ben at checkout for this
special offer if your screens aren't
easier on the eyes you can send them
back for a full refund try them for 30
days risk-free
that's Felix gray glasses comm so I
spend promo code been shipping and
returns totally free to Felix gray Felix
great glasses comm slash Ben use that
promo code Ben alrighty well we're going
to get into everything corona virus
related because the idiotic controversy
over when to reopen continues I say
idiotic because we're not actually
having the intelligent conversation at
this point it's basically people who
want to lock down forever against a few
people who want to open everything up in
willy-nilly fashion and then a bunch of
people in the middle saying how about we
go back to work in tranches and act
responsibly I think that's like 70% of
the American public at this point
seriously I think if you pull people and
you say here's our three options
lockdown until there's a vaccine and you
lose your job and the government will
try to pay you but the economy collapses
just get out there willy-nilly and start
smooching strangers or we can
responsibly reopen right now starting
with healthy populations we can wear
masks and we can socially distance I
think 70 percent of the American
population will be in that last group
we'll get to that in just a second first
this Sunday we have a great Sunday
special for you is with a midi sleighs
super relevant so a MIDI
the author of a fantastic book called
The Forgotten man about FDR and the
1930s and why all the measures taken
during the Great Depression were
absolute garbage shelfs is a fantastic
book on the Great Society and how
government attempts to alleviate poverty
have been a giant backfire in a giant
fail it's deeply relevant at a time when
you have the Democratic Party calling
for a whole scale remaking of the
economy yet again here's a little bit of
the preview guaranteed income tends to
break up families it makes it easier to
be a single autonomous adult if it
guaranteed income you know to stay
together families need to depend on one
another in order to be strong so it's
really a great episode of really
informative episode and her books are
really tremendous meanwhile it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily where remember
today it is Laura Dykstra who clearly
knows how to count their blessings in
this pick two adorably patriotically
dressed babies are sitting on the floor
together one deep in thought the other
fully surprised to be getting
photographs with not one but two
examples of the world's most elite
beverage vessel the caption reads good
things really do come in pairs couldn't
have said it better myself Laura those
two are a cuteness overload and the
babies are also really cute thanks for
sending in that magnificent pic and good
luck you've clearly got your hands full
by the way I believe that our offer for
two separate leftist ears tumblr is
still on the table so you can not have
those twins but you could actually have
the two left to steer so you can have
these twins twins man ok you can check
out those leftist heroes tumblers right
now when you go over to daily wire.com
slash subscribe I believe also we are
offering all access members 20% off so
go check out daily wire.com slash
subscribe you listening some of the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
it seems that many in the media now have
a vested interest in locking down and
forever and the case they are making is
not that they have a good alternative
they're locking down forever is even
credible it is not credible people are
going to go out they are and politicians
understand right now because of the
media coverage that the best available
option for them is blame Trump for the
economy and then take credit for saving
lives by walking down your city or
locking down your neighborhood unless
you're a responsible governor in which
case you are looking to responsibly
reopen and there are some bipartisan
responsible governor's again you're
looking at people like Jared policy in
Colorado looking at reopening he doesn't
get any sort of media play because
they're too busy the media turning this
into a polarized political issue when it
shouldn't be politicized here's the
narrative the media are now generating
the media is that if you want to reopen
in any way it's because you don't care
about human life that is the and this
follows hard on the Joe Biden line so
Joe Biden has been saying since the
beginning of the week his new line is we
need to fly flags at half-staff that
this is going to fix everything
so I played that clip a little bit
earlier of Joe Biden stumbling and
bumbling his way through that suggestion
within four hours the New York Times on
its front page put a piece suggesting
that President Trump is mean and doesn't
care about dead people the actual
headline was amid a rising death toll
Trump leaves the grieving to others you
see Trump's really mean and terrible by
the way here was Donald Trump yesterday
talking about mourning for every life
lost
tragically obscene the virus poses the
greatest risk to older Americans
together as one nation we mourn for
every precious life that has been lost
and there have been many there have been
many were so saddened by it through
aggressive actions and the devotion of
our doctors and nurses however we have
held our fatality rate far below
hard-hit other countries such as Spain
and Italy and United Kingdom and Sweden
yeah also first of all when it comes to
the the fatality per million rate that's
not actually true we are below UK we are
below Spain we are below Italy we're not
below Sweden and I don't know why he's
beating up on Sweden these days other
than Trump himself seems confused as to
what his actual policy should be here
the point here is that the media have
generated a narrative the narrative is
if you reopen you're killing people and
if you call for reopening you're calling
for killing people and so they're gonna
pick on Trump here the headline at the
New York Times was as the death toll
from the corona virus
for eight weeks surpasses the total
American military casualties in eight
years of major combat in Vietnam mr.
Trump has led no national mourning that
sentence in and of itself demonstrates
how stupid the media coverage is as
Peter Baker from the New York Times this
is not a war this is not in this is not
a war of choice like Vietnam this is not
we got in and then military strategy
decided how many people would die that
is not how this works
like this is a pandemic disease are you
insane everybody anybody who makes it a
Vietnam War comparison it's amazing you
get blasted by the media if you compare
this to the flu because it is not like
the flu in terms of deadliness or ease
of spread but it's a lot more like the
flu than it is like the Vietnam War
the Vietnam War was not contagious you
morons the Vietnam War was about
military strategy what a hell I'm gonna
need a way in which this is like the
Vietnam War other than there are a lot
of dead people that it is utterly unlike
the Vietnam War and yet you keep hearing
this comparison because the idea is that
it's Trump's Vietnam now always it's
it's Trump's Katrina it's Trump's
Vietnam it's come on it's just
irresponsible nonsense and again all of
this is driving a narrative the
narrative is that you're very mean and
very bad if you try to reopen the
economy and the media love picking the
nuts right they like picking on the
people who are being most irresponsible
in protesting this sort of stuff so for
example yesterday there are a bunch of
protesters who descended on the Michigan
Capitol because Michigan legislators are
voting on whether to extend the stay at
home orders and in the dumbest possible
fashion protesters show up carrying guns
and by the way I will note even this was
miss covered by the media here's what's
dumb about this screaming at police
officers who are attempting to enforce
social distance and getting right in
their faces while the police officers
are only wearing medical masks which
means that the police officers are
protecting others from being infected
and medical masks unless it's an n95 is
not gonna protect you from being
infected by others because you intake
air every time you breathe it getting
right in the faces of police officers
who are just trying to protect
legislators and keep people safe is
idiotic
do not do it it is idiotic and showing
up here with guns as though you're going
to invade the Capitol is a horrible look
it is a stupid look I've been saying for
a while you want to protest this stuff
go right ahead and protest it here's how
you should do it you should go to the
Capitol you should socially distance you
should wear a mask because the whole
point you're making is you are
responsible enough not
in fact tons of other people you're
responsible enough to be given your
freedom so when you appear to be
irresponsible and crazy all you are
doing is giving the other side the becan
to smack you with it's really really
stupid okay these were bad optics it was
stupid optics again I think most of the
people there are well-meaning
I think most of the people there are
correct that the economy should reopen
but you're really doing the opposite of
what you are intending to do with stuff
like this and the media loves it right
the media are totally into it by the way
when I say the medium is covered even
this must be frank about this it is not
against the law to come to the capital
with a gun unless they can show hostile
intent so members of the media cuz
they're scared of guns and they think
the guns are inherently evil they think
it shows hostile intent to show up
anyone with a gun so they said an anti a
program rally in Virginia which involved
like 10,000 people bringing guns and
involved zero actual violence with super
super threatening anytime reporters see
a gun they freak out like absolutely
freaked out these are the same kinds of
people who say if I have armed security
at my kids school and this is somehow
damaging to my child which is purely
insane but wait that's it was he was a
good optics no also quick note on media
malfeasance here every single one of
those protesters was temperature check
before they entered the building that
doesn't means that doesn't mean they're
coronavirus free there's a symptomatic
transmission it does mean that these
people were nonviolent enough to submit
so a temperature check before entering
the Michigan Capitol okay put all that
aside so on the one side you have the
people in the media who obviously want
to lock down forever and then you have
people like this who are being
irresponsible in how they protest and
creating bad optics and being stupid and
then you have everybody in the middle
who's like you know what guys they're
serious cost of this thing and we're
gonna have to reopen I'm amused to see
that the New York Times is finally
recognizing the capitalism raises people
out of poverty and that when you shut
down forcibly the world economy that
people get poor again there's an article
in The New York Times that that sort of
tacitly admits this there's a headline
millions who had risen out of poverty
are pulled back in by the pandemic let's
be frank it's not just the pandemic that
has pulled people back into poverty it
is government's forcibly shutting down
the free market economy that is pull
people back into poverty and changing
free market economy conditions based on
people not going out and participating
in a free market economy if government
was the solution to poverty I'm
wondering why did millions of people
just sink back into poverty during the
greatest government enforcement action
in the history of mankind
transnationally just wondering just just
just worth noting in the real world
the economy is actually quite a bad
thing quite a bad and and foolish thing
for doing it very long and what you're
seeing is people who are taking actions
that are completely unrelated to
responsibility so gavin newsom in
california and the media have created
this bizarre perception super bizarre
that gavin newsom in california has done
an amazing job rhonda xanthus in florida
has been evil and horrible greg abbott
in texas dean evil and horrible
last I checked California has about five
deaths per 100,000 population from
coronavirus Texas has three deaths per
100,000 population from coronavirus
Florida has six deaths per 100,000
population from coronavirus so why is it
the gavin newsom as a hero and ron
DeSantis is a fool when Ron de santis
has about the same stats as gavin newsom
except he didn't shut down his entire
state and is not threatening to shut
down every beach you have a newsroom by
the way even had to walk that back a
couple of days ago Gavin Newsome
suggested who's gonna shut down every
state park and Beach in the state
because a bunch of people showed up at
Newport Beach as I mentioned this is
like the dumbest possible policy why if
you're at the beach socially distancing
from other people that is basically the
safest place you could be right now
sunlight and free air kill the virus
sunlight and free air keep you away from
infecting other people in close
proximity to you like this is it there
was a study from China to count them two
cases of corona virus transmission in
the open air and was apparently two
people talking to each other at like one
foot distance with no masks so Gavin
Newsom had to walk that back he said
that he is a he's only going to close
state and local beaches in Orange County
which means of course now he's closed LA
County right LA County is closed Orange
County is closed so what is never gonna
get there and grab his hand iego then
drive back Oxnard that's all that's
gonna happen and then there'll be
overcrowding there because when you
squeeze people out of certain areas they
go to other areas yeah idiot they're
gonna go to the city parks that aren't
closed people aren't doing that here in
the area where I live we're just gonna
drive over to Burbank or Pasadena
we're not gonna stick around in LA
County we're just gonna drive over to
another city that isn't completely
insane in Washington DC there are
officials saying the city may not reopen
for three months for another three
months in Washington DC to this point in
washington DC there have been a grand
total of 190 deaths and they're gonna
shut the entire city of washington DC
for another three months based on what
to accomplish what a testing and tracing
regimen that is
only operative to prevent spikes you
note by the way when you're first gonna
see those spikes you're first gonna see
those spikes not in the testing and
tracing regimen not unless ramp up the
testing to millions per day you're first
gonna see it in hospital cases when
people suddenly spike in a particular
area I'm all for testing contact tracing
but can we stop pretending that is
utopian solution in which the virus
stops spreading and that the r goes
below one because of testing and tracing
in a country of 330 million people or
asymptomatic spread of the disease is
prevalent and we have over a million
cases that we've already identified
900,000 of them that that are still
active okay that none of this is going
to happen in the near future so let's be
real about this there's stupid people
who just say go out there and swap spit
with your local neighbors no matter your
age doesn't matter they're very few of
those very few then there's the media
elite we're like lockdown forever and
anybody who suggests differently is evil
and terrible and then there's everybody
in the middle and guess what everybody's
gonna end up in the middle every single
person who is not insane is gonna end up
in the middle no matter what the media
try to push here okay they're not gonna
listen to dr. Karen Landman over at the
New York Times saying George went first
and it screwed up because guess what
somebody was gonna have to go first and
there's no evidence that George just
screwed this up and if you just say oh
well there will be an elevation in cases
guess what that's called reality when
you let people out of lockdown of course
there's elevation in cases frankly I'm
kind of shocked that we still are not
getting national data on who exactly is
dying and from what their stats out
today by the way that demonstrates that
the vast majority of people who are
dying again and who are young are people
who have serious underlying conditions
not just hypertension if you're under 50
people who are obese people who have HIV
people who have asthma if you are young
and you are healthy statistically
speaking you are not going to die of
this disease hey you the chances of you
dying of the disease I read the stats
yesterday are extraordinarily low for
young people and so you're gonna start
seeing is everybody treating this like
Sweden that's what's gonna happen and
that's the responsible way to treat this
thing just everybody's late on it of
course and then the polarized media
production here is is something to
behold okay time for some things I like
and then a quick thing that I hate or
not so quick thing that I hate so things
I like today so there is a series that
came out in 2018 on FX I believe it is
now on Netflix
it is a miniseries called Waco about the
Waco assault by the Fed
government and it is the most absurdly
libertarian series in the history of
television
I mean absurdly libertarian because the
entire series is basically about how the
FBI like all other federal agencies is
staffed by people who are
self-interested by people who want to
maximize their budget not lose their
jobs and how they will use the elements
of law enforcement in order to maximize
their political their political upside
and take risks with the lives of other
people that are completely unjustified
that's really what this is about the
series traces the FBI and its activities
from Ruby Ridge through Waco it starts
off with Ruby Ridge now a lot of people
are not old enough to remember Ruby
Ridge frankly I don't really remember at
Waco particularly while it happened in
1993 I was 9 at the time and I didn't
follow it too closely but Ruby Ridge was
a situation in which there was a gun
charge that was brought against this guy
who was sort of a quasi with accusations
where they used white supremacists he
was a he was a sort of libertarian
anarchist and he had a a farm up in a
place called Ruby Ridge in Idaho and the
federal government came in the ATF and
the FBI came in and they proceeded to
negotiate with him for like two minutes
and then the FBI got in a gun battle
with his son and killed his 13 year old
son they shot his 13 year old son to
death in in a kind of confrontation in
the woods then they proceeded to shoot
his wife and kill his wife then he came
out who's convinced to come out by
negotiators with the FBI he was put on
trial for the gun charge and he was
acquitted so they so the FBI went in
guns blazing in a situation for a gun
charge this underscores a basic point
that I've always made when you are
calculating whether a law is worth
enforcing or making understand that at
the end of every law is the threat of
death from the government every single
law the Everett the threat of death from
the government exists at the end of that
law why because let's say that you have
a high flush toilet and you violate an
EPA standard because your toilet flushes
too much water and the federal
government comes to your door and they
say we're gonna find you so you know I'm
not paying that fine and so we're gonna
lean your property you say well I'm not
leaving my property they say well then
we're gonna come arrest you say well I'm
not going with you at the end of every
law at the end of every law is if you
resist the law they will shoot you and
so knowing that you should take pretty
seriously the kind of laws that we make
in this kind
three understanding that most people are
not going to resist the law understand
most people will pay the fine
understanding all of that and
understanding that there are certain
areas where the where the there is
interest in regulation right you are
going to have to regulate people from
damaging each other but if you are doing
something that doesn't damage another
human being and the federal government
is threatening to murder you over it
then that's that's kind of a big problem
okay the serious kind of makes that
point with regard to the the Branch
Davidians in in wake up
so the Branch Davidians were not good
people I mean the Branch Davidians were
engaged in a cult in which the leader of
the Branch Davidians David Koresh was
essentially engaged in in sexual assault
of young girls in which he was engaged
in polygamy which was fathering children
by other men's wives with their
permission but some of these women some
of these people were girls I mean was
like more than was 14 when he married
her pretty gross stuff but but the
series makes the point that pretty much
all of this was legal in the state of
Texas and even the gun charges that the
ATF went into police could have been
alleviated with like a twenty five
dollar fine okay and so they went in
guns blazing and 130 and to a compound
130 people 76 people died including 25
children and the series traces like
every step of this in apparently fairly
accurate fashion because they were
consulting with somebody who was inside
the compound and ended up escaping at
last minute and they consulted with Gary
knizner who is the who's the negotiator
on behalf of the FBI the series you know
there's a case you may the series is is
too sympathetic toward kourosh that it
should have exact that it that really
should have examined more of the bad
stuff the chorus was doing but as people
in the series point out or there's
national radio host in the series who
who is talking about it almost as
running commentary the ATF is not in is
not enforceable child abuse agency and
there are accusations the chorus was
abusing children we have agencies for
that right we have Child Protective
Services that's not the ATF's job the
ATF going in guns blazing over gun
charges that were fairly minut and then
basically bringing tanks into the area
for political gain is fairly insane
here's a little bit of the trailer it is
it's disturbing stuff and again it is a
great reminder that we should be very
careful about the power you give to the
federal government because you never
know when that power of the federal
government is turned against you and
that power is enormous the government
I've said before is a giant gun and at
the end of every law is that giant guns
would be very careful how you deploy
that giant gun
you've looked me to be your leader to
guide you on this journey but I'm no
leader I'm a follower just like you
[Applause]
God has instructed me to stay here and
wait for his son
[Music]
this is our time to prove through
suffering that we are worthy of the
miracle that's the color
[Music]
[Applause]
it is the most libertarians series I
have ever seen in my in my life and it's
and it is fairly well rounded in the
sense that you know Koresh is obviously
not a good person Koresh is obviously a
bad guy but he is a true believer in his
own in his own stick they they don't
make it as though he's a cynical user
which he may very well a bit right he
may have been a guy who just wanted to
up everybody else's wife and so he
created a false prophecy in which he had
to shoot up everybody else's wife and
people went along with it but the series
is is pretty it's pretty definitive on
its own view that the federal government
is responsible for the deaths inside
that compound right it does not make any
bones about the idea that this was not a
mass suicide that this was in fact the
federal government completely blowing it
it's it's worth watching as it is a an
excellent reminder for all those who
love government force and are willing to
use it in nearly any circumstance that
it's all fun and games until the
government decides that you're the bad
guy based on whatever pretext they can
raise that day okay time for a thing
that I hate ok the utter and essential
dishonesty of members of the media who
are taking people out of context on this
pandemic thing is truly extraordinary is
extraordinary
so you remember early on president from
suggested that the Democrats were
engaged in a hoax by blaming him for all
the impacts of coronavirus and this
became a talking point for the Democrats
who then claimed that Trump was actually
saying that coronavirus itself was a
hoax
he never said coronavirus itself was a
hoax but this became the talking point
and Nancy Pelosi went on TV and repeated
every day didn't matter it was a for
Pinocchio claim according to The
Washington Post did not matter it has
been trotted out ever since to claim
that President Trump claims that
coronavirus itself was a hoax
well now the Democrats have a second
round of this so Jared Kushner who's a
chief adviser to the president he goes
on television and he says listen the
federal response to this thing has been
a success story not the corona virus is
a success story the federal government's
response to this is a success story
because we responded as governors need
us to respond here is what Jared
questioner said and then we will explain
and then we'll show how it has been
deliberately twisted by members of the
media to suggest that Jared Kushner is
celebrating 60,000 dead American it's
just this kind of stuff is just sheer
garbage here is Jared Kushner on Fox &
Friends the other day we're on the other
side of the medical aspect of this and I
think that we've achieved all the
different milestones that are needed so
the government federal government rose
to the challenge and this is a great
success story
and and I think that that's really you
know what needs to be told
okay so again he is saying that the
federal government's success here is a
story that needs to be told a hundred
percent true a hundred percent true all
you've seen you sought for weeks where
do the ventilators where the ventilators
why isn't from doing a better job on
ventilators people can't act as their
own ventilators first of all that was
always exaggerated to a certain extent
because guess what the death rate on
ventilators is it is by most studies in
excess of 90 percent but beyond off of
that guess what didn't happen thirty
thousand ventilators needed in New York
it was not necessary and when Trump said
they're not gonna need 30,000
ventilators in New York he was torn
apart for it Andrew Cuomo says they will
how many ventilators were needed not 30
I don't believe they need ten the
federal government got them the
ventilators they the federal government
has been responsible for getting people
the personal protective equipment the
federal government has been responsible
for a seven trillion dollar bailout the
federal government responds here has
been as active as any response in the
history of America and more active than
virtually all of them and you know who
is saying that sort of stuff Democrats
Governor Phil Murphy of New Jersey no
Ally to the President of the United
States
he says New Jersey's getting pretty hard
hit right now he says listen the federal
government is giving us the supplies we
need were receiving what we need from
the Trump administration you've heard
the same message from Andrew Cuomo
you've heard the same message from Gavin
Newsom Democrat jay Inslee Democrats
across the nation have been consistently
saying over and over and over we ask the
federal government for this and we got
it rich and whipper in Michigan says
this I'm frankly I'm shocked that the
Trump administration is not cut and add
so far or the Trump campaign has not cut
an ad that just has all the various
Democrats saying we asked for what we
need and we got it because that is true
and here is Phil Murphy yesterday saying
this can't thank the president and his
team enough in terms of what we've
gotten already in terms of ventilators
bed capacity for the Army Corps PPE etc
but we we are embarking upon a very
significant partnership to more than
double expand our testing amounts and
numbers in New Jersey by at latest the
end of May so there he is explaining the
federal government has done its job the
federal government I know buried lead
the federal government has done his job
this is not Trump's Katrina
by the way Bush's Katrina wasn't Bush's
Katrina but this is not Trump's Katrina
is sound Trump's Vietnam the Trump
administration put aside the dumb stuff
that Trump says in press conferences
because that's just Trump being Trump
and we all get it and anybody who
pretends not to get it is being
deliberately obtuse we all understand
what Trump is and what he has said and
we understand what anybody does we all
get it and anybody who doesn't is lying
to you here's the reality
the federal government did its job that
is a success story the media will not
tell that success story I would
guarantee that if you do a search for
offensive waiters right now in the media
if you just search the word ventilators
that the New York Times in the media you
will see this enormous spike in the
early days when the demands were
ventilators ventilators ventilators
ventilators and then the federal
government got them the ventilators and
then gone when's the last time you heard
somebody on national TV mentioned the
word ventilators it's been a while huh
you know why cuz New York didn't exhaust
its need for it didn't exhaust the
supply ventilators no one has remember
when they said we don't have enough
hospital beds in New York and the feds
were like okay well we'll get you the
hospital beds you need guess what didn't
happen in an overrun of the hospital
system Andrew Cuomo sent away the US
Navy ship comfort remember is a huge
story when the comfort arrived not as
big a story when it went away it was it
so.when Jared Kushner says it was a
success story about the federal
government that's because it was a
success story by the federal government
and they continued to work to provide
for the needs of states many of which
should have been providing for these
needs themselves ok so this all leads up
to the media deliberately
misinterpreting Kushner cuz Kushner is
very bad he's a very bad guy because
Jared questioner works for Trump and
he's related to Trump because he's
married to Trump's daughter and this
means the Kushner is bad and evil and
terrible and no-good and very bad by the
way in the history of American politics
and I understand I'm not a big fan of
nepotism either but to pretend that
Jared Kushner is unique in the history
of American politics is a complete
absurdity visit this this goes back
quite a way the person who was
effectively running the country when
when Woodrow Wilson went down in 1919
right he had a heart attack and he's
basically not with us was Edith his wife
was running the country his son-in-law
McAdoo William McAdoo was the Secretary
of War under and so the Jared Kushner of
his time was the Secretary of War not an
advisor to the President the Secretary
of War under Woodrow Wilson
I believe so the so nepotism the
Kennedys the Clintons tell me about
nepotism okay so
the view here is the view yesterday
deliberately misinterpreting questioners
comments to suggest that he was saying
that it was a success that 60,000 people
had died those were some of the most
tone-deaf comments I've heard from the
administration we know that Jared
Kushner has been sort of the
behind-the-scenes task force leader
Korona task force leader he's been
instrumental in this response this
piss-poor response and 60,000 Americans
have lost their lives so to call this a
rousing success story is is a shocking
it's cruel okay sending Hostin I would
like to hear you define the piss-poor
response really well what should they
have done better what were the things
they should have done better and the
Democrats were something for heavily in
in February I really the the widespread
media lie that the federal government's
response has been piss-poor
is absolutely rebutted by Democratic
governor after Democratic governor
saying we asked for what we need and
then we got it from the feds and the
attempt to twist what Kushner is saying
into yes we're happy with 60,000 that is
insane it's totally insane but again
this is the media basically saying that
Trump is a bad mean man who doesn't care
about human beings and that's why he
wants to reopen and it's it's all it's
all ridiculous alrighty so we'll be back
here a little bit later today with two
additional hours of content well gets
all the Michael Flynn's stuff then we'll
also be getting to your questions in the
mailbag so go subscribe over daily we're
calm / subscribe of special deal on this
is the last week by the way when our
all-access live episodes are gonna be
available to non All Access members so
you should subscribe right now because
we're gonna keep those going like next
week I'm still gonna be answering your
questions and wearing t-shirts and all
the rest but you're not gonna be able to
see any of the gun show unless you are
actually an all-access Live member so
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike poor Amina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen